Just when you think you're out
of the "Veronica Mars" fandom,
they pull you back in. Buckle up, Marshmallows,
because we're taking a road trip back to
Neptune to investigate a potential Season 5.
In the fall of 2018, Hulu announced
that it would air an eight-episode
revival of "Veronica Mars" slated for
release in 2019. By July of that year,
fans around the world were gearing up for a new
season that was years in the making. After the
2014 "Veronica Mars" movie – which was largely
regarded as total fan service — audiences were
excited to see Veronica back in episodic format,
especially since creator and showrunner Rob
Thomas promised a grittier reboot that felt more
like the original series that premiered in 2004.
Season 4 of "Veronica Mars" ended up dropping
a week early on July 19, 2019, after the cast
and crew assembled for a panel at that year's
San-Diego Comic Con. Of course, viewers rushed
to binge the short series and get their fix as
fast as possible. Both fans and critics liked the
season — so why has Season 5 never come to pass?
As Thomas revealed to TVLine in 2019, he has ideas
for more stories in mind. But Hulu made it clear
at that time that they had no interest in further
Veronica Mars adventures, and their opinion
doesn't seem to have changed. Nowadays, Thomas
is busy with the "Party Down" reboot, and Bell has
been devoting her time to productions like "Frozen
3," "Central Park," and "The Woman in the House
Across the Street from the Girl in the Window."
They might still be down to return to Neptune, but
if Hulu isn't into it, it's unlikely to happen.
"Blows that would destroy most people?
She always picks herself back up."
Most of the core cast of "Veronica Mars"
ended up returning for the Season 4 revival,
including Kristen Bell, Jason Dohring, Enrico
Colantoni, Percy Daggs III, Ryan Hansen,
and Francis Capra. The season also brought
in a handful of new faces like Patton Oswalt,
Kirby Howell-Baptiste, and even
Academy Award-winner J.K. Simmons.
It remains to be seen which members of the cast
would return for a possible Season 5 — but one
actor definitely wouldn't. Fans were shocked,
dismayed, and heartbroken when Logan Echolls, the
love of Veronica's life, was killed by one last
bomb at the end of Season 4. Dohring is confident
that Logan would remain six feet under in any
future installments, but noted that it's possible
"Veronica Mars" could bring new and old faces back
to Neptune again. As far as Bell is concerned,
she's definitely in for "Veronica Mars" Season 5
if it happens: As the star remarked at Comic-Con:
"I'll play Veronica until
everyone in Neptune is dead."
The end of "Veronica Mars" Season 4 sees Veronica
hit the highest highs and lowest lows of her life
thus far. After marrying her longtime love Logan
and committing to their relationship once and for
all, she ends up watching as Logan falls victim to
a car bomb meant for her, hidden as one last gift
from Penn Epler, the season's villain. One year
later, Veronica is finally seeking therapy — which
was a huge bone of contention between Veronica
and Logan while he was alive — and leaving
Neptune seemingly for good, taking to the road
to pick up more cases for Mars Investigations.
This ending definitely opens the door for plenty
more mysteries, and Season 5 could possibly focus
on Veronica's post-Neptune career as well
as the goings-on at Mars Investigations back
in California. Regarding the latter setting,
Keith has taken a new Veronica-esque protégé
named Matty under his wing; her father was
killed in the first spring break bombing.
"I guess I just wanna go into
this with my eyes wide open."
Were "Veronica Mars" to earn a Season 5, it would
have to find a way to handle the elephant in the
room: Logan's sudden, shocking death by car
bomb. Why did he have to go in such brutal,
tragic fashion? According to Rob
Thomas, it was necessary. He told ET:
"It's like cutting off a limb to
save the body. 'Veronica Mars'
had no future with him in tow. My
feeling is that if we move forward,
it has to move forward as a noir detective show.
And it's hard to do that when your kick-ass noir
detective has a boyfriend back home. It
becomes increasingly difficult to work."
Many fans were outraged by the loss, but
Thomas has no regrets. When TVLine asked
him if he'd reconsidered the decision,
his answer was swift and assured:
"No. Not even a little bit. I know what the
show needs to be moving forward ... There's a
reason shows end when the couple gets together.
I'm not going to start doing 'The Thin Man.'
It's not going to be Veronica and Logan solving
mysteries, so what is Logan doing in the show?"
He knew fans would be upset, and even
accepted their ire as valid, saying that he
won't "begrudge" them if they aren't willing
to watch a "Veronica Mars" without Logan.